2014 was the year of the hacker so for
2015 a number of companies here at ces
want to replace your password with
something much harder to steal your
biometrics see we are all like
snowflakes we all have unique physical
characteristics and if these companies
are onto something your future password
could just be your own body
if you want to feel like you're in a
mission impossible movie ilock's myrus
comes pretty close
mirus is an eye scanner that uses the
color and texture of your iris to
identify you allowing you to log into
your computer or unlock the door to your
house you just put your face up to the
device which scans your eye with an
infrared camera and you're good to go
the company claims this is many times
harder to fake than a fingerprint reader
ilock just announced plans to build the
technology into laptops which makes
logging in about as simple as looking at
the top of your screen
the nimiband identifies you by your
heartbeat snap the magnetic clasp onto
your wrist then touch the top with your
other hand to complete an electric
circuit with your body and the miniband
is able to read the electric activity of
your heart it can then identify you by
the shape of your electrocardiogram wave
the canadian startup that makes the
device is in the early stages of mimi's
development but the company's grand
vision of the future is that this band
is all you would need to access pretty
much everything shopping airports hotels
you name it you wouldn't need your
wallet or even your phone although let's
be honest your phone is pretty much an
extension of your arm at this point
last but not least forget your password
just take a selfie hoyoslabs biometric
technology uses your phone's camera to
take an image of your face then analyzes
more than 2000 key points on your face
to confirm that you are in fact you for
added security you can turn up what the
company calls liveness detection so you
have to smile or raise your eyebrows to
identify yourself right now the
technology is integrated into hoyos
lab's 1u app which lets you log into
websites but the company has plans to
make their biometrics compatible with
atm machines banking apps even starting
your car of course that would mean
having to look at your own face on a
cell phone camera several times a day
which depending on your point of view
could be excruciating or wonderful